one of them this year the time 100 gala
is back to gleaming with glitz and
glamour but as it celebrated its annual
list of the world's most influential
people it was a guest of honor who
couldn't attend that provided the
biggest impact
millions of people may starve if
russia's blockade of the black sea
continues in accepting his honor
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
also spoke directly about the crisis
still gripping his people and
underscored the potential for a
catastrophic global food crisis if
ukrainian grain exports don't soon
restart
russia is
is clearly weaponizing food
the ongoing war between russia and
ukraine the world's third and fourth
largest grain exporters has fueled food
price inflation and put global grain
supplies at risk developing countries
are the hardest hit civil unrest is
already intensifying in countries like
sri lanka
where police clashed with protesters
again thursday
the united nations compares the looming
famine to a gathering storm
ukraine's food production and the food
and fertilizer produced by russia
must be brought back into world markets
despite the war
the u.n is working with turkey trying to
broker a deal to lift russia's blockade
of ukraine's ports
we see it as a reasonable and
implementable plan said turkey's foreign
minister after meeting with his russian
counterpart though talks have been
described as fruitful so far there has
been no breakthrough after weeks of
bargaining
the russian side as usual is playing its
stupid games said ukraine's ambassador
to turkey ukrainian officials claim the
kremlin is imposing unreasonable
conditions
russia says free shipment depends on an
end to western sanctions care at home
access to food is not in danger but
prices will continue to rise sylvan
charles points to a potential peak this
fall dan spectre global news montreal